[Musique]
nous sommes plusieurs centaines de
personnes dans cette salle où il fait
assez sombre à votre avis que se
passerait-il si un incendie venait à se
déclencher
il ya bien des issues de secours
ici ou là signalé par des petites
lumières vertes
mais concrètement si un feu prenait dans
les coulisses derrière moi comment
serions nous les uns les autres se
diriger vers ces issues de secours au
bon endroit et être ainsi sauver des
fumées toxiques et des flammes chacun
d'entre nous ici peut tirer l'alertent
incendie et c'est ce qui fait que nous
sentons tranquille c'est cette
responsabilité partagée qui fait que
nous nous sentons en sécurité et que
bien évidemment nous remercieront celui
d'entre nous qui aurait tiré l'alarmé
incendie
et ça c'est le fonctionnement normal
mais parfois il arrive qu'on ne veuille
pas que vous dansiez l' alerte et là les
conséquences peuvent vous emmener très
loin en juin 2008
je travaille pour ubs
je suis responsable marketing et
communication depuis neuf années ma
supérieure hiérarchique nouvellement
recrutés entre dans mon bureau
anxieuse
et énervée elle m'explique qu'une
perquisition vient d'avoir lieu dans le
bureau du directeur général
je la cite vous comprenez étant donné
les circonstances
dépêchez vous c'est important je ressens
juste que quelque chose ne va pas et je
vais décider de lancer l' alerte en
interne comme il n'ya pas de manuels de
lanceurs d'alert je pose des questions à
des collègues je me rapproche de nos
instances du personnel et de
l'inspection du travail qui sont là pour
nous aider mais nous protéger aussi je
pose des questions à des collègues
banquiers dont les réponses claires me
choque
on m'apprend que la maison mère qu ubs
en suisse a organisé un vaste système
d'évasion fiscale à l'international et
que la filiale française pour laquelle
je travaillais complices de ces
agissements
je rencontre alors séparément certains
dirigeants de la banque et leur explique
tétanisé ce que je viens de découvrir
grâce à toutes ces discussions
je signale à ses dirigeants
ce que mes collègues banquiers m'ont
expliqué c'est dysfonctionnements mise
en place par la banque qui aurait donc
organisé un vaste système international
tournés vers la banque offshore
notamment vers la suisse à l'époque ça
s'appelle de l'évasion fiscale en bande
organisée et que c'est complètement
illégal et que se taire c'est en être
complice
et moi à ce moment là je pense
simplement qu'on va me remercier de
l'intérêt que je porte au fonctionnement
et à la réputation de mon entreprise
et puis aussi comme si quelqu'un ici
tiré l'alarmé incendie
je pensais que ma vie allait reprendre
comme avant mais j'avais tout faux
j'avais complètement tort j'avais lancé
l' alerte mais ma drh ont directeur
juridique mon président mon directeur
général celui là même dans le bureau a
été perquisitionné et qui aujourd'hui
huit années plus tard plaide coupable
dans ce dossier pénal me disent tous que
je suis fatigué que je dois prendre des
vacances que j'invente une histoire et
que on vient ici ou là se plaindre
auprès d'eux
je ne serai plus tout à fait compétente
l'art le fait de parler d'expliquer que
j'avais compris qu'un dysfonctionnement
avait lieu ça m'a été reproché
suite à mes signalement mais évaluation
sud drastiquement moi qui depuis neuf
ans était relativement bien notés pour
aller jusqu à ce poste de responsable
marketing et communication subitement je
suis incompétente voire même on me
reproche mon niveau d'anglais qui
pourtant on n'a jamais été un problème
surtout quand on sait c'est assez
surprenant que je n'ai jamais parlé
qu'en anglais à mes enfants
avec une telle évaluation
je suis de fait déclasser je deviens
début 2009 responsable des hôtesses à
laitages de la banque
où sont accueillis les clients ma
nouvelle mission consiste à assurer de
la propreté des bureaux de l'hygiène de
la cuisine et m'assurer que les fleurs
et les plantes vertes sont bien arrosée
à l'été 2009 suite à des signalements
l'inspection du travail me demandent de
porter plainte contre la banque pour
évasion fiscale et blanchiment de
capitaux en bande organisée auprès du
procureur de la république ce que je
fais avec l'aide de mon avocat de
l'époque et à la même période
la banque avait envisagé un plan de
licenciement de 100 personnes dans
lequel j'étais incluses et il se passe
quelque chose que j'ai toujours du mal à
comprendre cette même inspection du
travail qui m'a demandé de porter
plainte contre mon employeur accepte
sans sourcilier le lit sans le
licenciement de mai 99 collègues et
refuse le mien pourquoi pourquoi me
laisser enfermer chez un employeur qui
fraude et qui me rétrograde parce que
j'ai dénoncé ces fraudes
en parallèle à ces reproches à ces
vexations que je vis au quotidien dans
l'entreprise il m'arrive quelque chose
digne d'une scène d'un scénario
hollywoodien
je reçois un appel en numéro masqué sur
mon téléphone portable
après quelques phrases je comprends
qu'il s'agit d'un service de douane qui
dépend du ministère des finances on me
donne rendez-vous dans paris on
m'accompagne dans le sous sol d'un grand
magasin parisien où l'on me montre des
insignes d'écart
où nos couleurs nationales et république
française sont bien apparents je me sens
tellement soulagé enfin mais sauveur
sont arrivés j'ai dénoncé un
dysfonctionnement en interne
j'ai lancé l' alerte il ya trois ans
déjà j'ai porté plainte
il y a deux ans et je suis enfin entendu
ces agences et fonctionnaires m'explique
que chez ubs la fraude continue et il me
convoque trois jours plus tard pour une
audition longue de plus de neuf heures
on m'explique le ministère a besoin de
preuves de pièces supplémentaires
cette opération qui consiste donc à
fournir des informations des données des
renseignements dure plus d'une année où
je suis obligé de transmettre à chaque
rendez vous des informations
confidentielles qui appartiennent à la
banque dont je suis toujours l'une des
cadres et si vous étiez dans un scénario
hollywoodien il y aurait forcément une
scène où on vous parlerai de votre
protection et de votre sécurité
mais là rien on ne me parle ni de
protection ni de lanceurs d'alert ni de
statut d'un viseur des douanes alors que
le statut existe deux ans plus tard à
l'été 2013
après nombreuses perquisitions
ubs s'est mise en examen une première
fois une deuxième fois
une troisième fois ce qui est bien
évidemment me soulage mais il se passe
un événement inattendu pour la première
fois je suis médiatisé mais
qui a donné mon nom aux médias pourquoi
mon anonymat n'at-il pas été respectées
pourquoi n'ai-je pas été protégé à
l'époque je n'en sais rien mais je
déclare que je fais confiance en la
justice de notre pays puisque l'évasion
fiscale est un délit et que 60 à 80
milliards d'euros quitte la france
chaque année
en même temps je commence à aller un peu
mieux
j'envoie des cv pour reprendre une vie
professionnelle puisque le fait d'avoir
dénoncé en interne ces
dysfonctionnements avaient arrêté ma
carrière j'en vois plus de 1000 cv rien
aucune réponse mon anonymat n'avaient
pas été respectées la protection n'avait
pas été assurée je ne pouvais donc plus
retourner dans une vie normale un
lanceur d' alerte
c'est quelqu'un qui se lève dans
l'intérêt général pour mettre la lumière
des informations qui étaient cachées au
plus grand nombre
son intention est d'agir dans l'intérêt
général
personne ou presque ne sais que nous ne
sommes pas protégés
voire pire que nous sommes en danger et
si l'un d'entre vous essayez de nous
aider il ne serait peut-être pas
protégés dans mon cas j'ai refusé d'être
complice de mécanismes illégaux
illicites mise en place par mon ex
employeur je n'ai fait qu'obéir aux
administrations et obtempéré auprès de
fonctionnaires assermentés
on en arrive au paradoxe
que les lanceurs d'alert qui se lève
dans l'intérêt général et qui comme moi
permettent à l'état français de
récupérer 12 milliards d'euros ne sont
ni remercier ni protéger et leur
anonymat n'est pas protégée non plus ni
leur protection financière assurée pour
ma part j'aurais dû bénéficier en 2011
d'un statut des viseurs des douanes qui
aurait permis justement de protéger mon
anonymat et de me faire repartir vers
une vie professionnelle normale d'autant
plus surprenant que le statut existe aux
états unis le statut de lens hors d'elle
d'alert existent et les personnes qui en
bénéficient sont protéger leur anonymat
est garanti et leur sécurité financière
aussi neuf années se sont écoulées
j'étais responsable marketing et
communication d'une grande marque
internationale et je gagnais
convenablement ma vie depuis deux ans et
demi je vis des minima sociaux et dans
deux mois je ne sais pas où j'irai
habiter ce n'est malheureusement pas une
figure de style mais vous pouvez tous
être des lanceurs d'alert tire l alarme
incendie
ici dans cette salle en est un exemple
dénoncé des maltraitances sur des
enfants sur des personnes handicapées
sur nos seniors l'êtes aussi dénoncé des
médicaments qui tue au lieu de soigner
les tout autant mais si l'un d'entre
vous tire l alarme incendie et que les
pompiers décident d'évacuer tout le
monde et vous laisse vous au milieu des
flammes ce que serait normal
dans le pays des droits de l'homme
n'est-il pas indispensable que celui qui
se lève pour protéger son pays pour
protéger les autres soit lui aussi
protégé il s'agit là d'intégrité de
vivre ensemble de transparence de bon
sens parce que les informations que nous
avons mises à la lumière ont permis de
découvrir cet entre soi et cette opacité
et on sait tous que l'opacité conduit à
l'impunité avec bienveillance
je ne peux que vous rappeler que si un
feu prenait dans cette salle nous ne
penserions ni les uns ni les autres a
abandonné à laisser brûler celui qui
tirait la sonnette d'alarmé
faisons en sorte les uns et les autres
que le statut de lanceurs d'alert soit
reconnu et surtout appliquer je remercie
de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]